Ok. Ekrem, jetzt generell die Fälle, die wir hier sprechen, oder du machst deine Ausführungen und dann machen wir es?
Ok, ich mache meine Ausführungen und dann machen wir es.
Ok, danke.
Herzlichen Dank.
Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Es geht um Vera Hoppenstedt, 63 Jahre alt, geboren am 10.2.1962.
68 Kilo wiegt und 1,76 Meter groß.
Sie stellt sich heute bei uns wegen einer stundedauerhaften Schwinde vor.
Sie steht heute beim Spaziergang.
Sie dauert mindestens eine Stunde.
Die Patienten klagen über jede zwei Wochen ähnliche Attacke.
Die letzten zwei Wochen wurden die Beschwerden schlimmer.
Sie erwähnten auch eine gleichzeitig Kopfschmerzen, aber nicht so stark.
Leider habe ich die Schmerzintensität-Fragen vergessen.
Bei der Vegetative-Anamnese klagt sie über überall, aber keine Erbröchen, dauerhafte Verstopfung, Schlafstörungen.
Sie kann auch in der Nacht zweimal Wasser lassen.
Was ist der Fachbegriff?
Nukturi.
Nein, Wasser lassen, Nukturi.
Ansonsten ist die Vegetative-Anamnese unauffällig.
Vor Erkrankungen, sie erwähnt seit fünf Jahren, Arteriellhypotenie bei Ihnen bekannt, aber seit drei Jahren ein Medikament eingenommen.
Er nimmt täglich Amlodipin, Leider-Dosierung nicht bekannt.
Amlodipin ist ein 5 mg Tablett.
Amlodipin ist ein 8-Lebensjahr-Appendiktum.
Bei der Voroperation, bei Ihnen würde mit 8 Lebensjahren eine Appendiktum und mit 13 Jahren Lebensjahr eine Translektum und vor 8 Jahren eine Hysteriktum.
Sie äußert Gebärmutter und Ayastöke alle entfernt.
Dann wird die Operation komplikationell durchgeführt.
Keine Allergie.
Nikotinkonsum seit fünf Jahren nicht rauchen, aber vorher seit 20 Jahren täglich sein Zigaretten.
Der Drogenkonsum würde bejaht.
Alkoholkonsum, Alkoholkonsum, eine Flasche Bier am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Familienanamnese.
Die Mutter mit 75 Jahren plötzlich gestorben.
Grund dafür leider nicht bekannt.
Der Vater hat 80 Jahre.
Er hatte vor fünf Jahren einen Schlaganfall.
Er leidet an Arterialhypertonie und lebt aktuell in einem Altenheim.
Sie hatte einen Bruder.
Sein Bruder hatte einen rauchen Bein.
Ein Bein wurde amputiert.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Entgleisung der Arterialhypertonie.
Wofür spricht die Entgleisung der Arterialhypertonie?
Unkontrolliert.
Entgleisung der entkontrollierten Arterialhypertonie.
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen.
Haben Sie mich gehört?
Ich habe gefragt, wofür spricht die unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie?
Welche Symptome oder Besonderheiten hatte die Patientin?
Frau Hoppenstedt hat gesagt, sie hatte letztes Mal ihren Hausarzt vor einem Jahr besucht.
Sie nimmt seine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Die letzte Blutdruckmessung war vor zwei oder drei Wochen.
Sie hatte keine Blutdruckmesse.
Wie hoch war das?
Leider nicht bekannt.
Sie haben gesagt, vor zwei Wochen hat sie ihren Blutdruck gemessen.
Haben Sie nicht gefragt, wie hoch war das?
Leider habe ich das Fragen vergessen.
Okay. Aber wenn Sie diese Fragen bekommen, sagen Sie zuerst, welche Symptome die Patientin hat.
Sie klagt über Schwindel, Kopfschmerzen und Übelkeit.
Sie leidet in der Feuerkrankenanamnese.
Sie leidet an Arterialhypertonie.
Leider ist ihr Blutdruck seit zwei oder drei Wochen nicht gemessen.
Die Schmerzen waren erhöht.
Deswegen habe ich den Verdacht auf unkontrollierte Hypertonie.
Sie haben sehr gut erklärt. Aber zuerst sollen Sie die Beschwerden nennen.
Ich verstehe. Danke für die Information.
Die Patientin hat seit zwei Wochen verschlimmerte Schwindel und leichte Kopfschmerzen.
Sie hat unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie.
Die letzte Kontrolle war mindestens zwei Wochen.
Sie hat keine regelmäßigen Hausarztbesuche.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose kommen Sie zu?
Differenzialdiagnose kommen aus der Symptome und Hypertonie.
Hypotereose.
Die Patienten sind immer stressig.
Welche weitere Diagnostikmaßnahmen würden Sie durchführen?
Ich würde gerne als Erstes den körperlichen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann würde ich einen kardologischen und einen psychiatrischen Konsul durchführen.
Was halten Sie bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen...
Ich bin wirklich eine sehr schwere Patientin.
Schwindel und Kopfschmerzen. Sie haben eine neurologische.
Ja, aber bei den Schwindel...
Ja, Augenuntersuchungen sind sehr wichtig.
Und eine neurologische Untersuchung werde ich durchführen.
Und dann Bluthochdruckmessung ist sehr wichtig.
Und dann Schilddruckunguntersuchungen sind auch sehr wichtig.
Und? Können Sie mir bitte helfen?
Ja, Sie haben schon sehr gut erklärt.
Bei den körperlichen Untersuchungen achten Sie darauf,
dass Sie Schilddrücke prallpieren auf eine neurologische Ausfälle.
Und natürlich überprüfen Sie die Vitalparameter wie Blutdruck.
Ja, das ist genug.
Alles Gute, vielen Dank.
Welche operative Methode führen Sie durch?
Welche operative Methode?
Welche Information haben Sie?
Ich habe keine Information.
Ich denke, dass ich diese Fälle nicht mehr verfolgen kann.
Aber Sie denken, Sie können die Hypertone nicht kontrollieren?
Vielleicht können Sie eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich würde gerne eine langsätzliche EKG und langsätzliche EKG kontrollieren.
Langsätzliche EKG oder langsätzliche Blutdruck?
Blutdruck.
Messung.
Sie haben eine Asyperansialdiagnose, Hypoteroese genannt.
Dann sollen Sie eine Ultraschalldiffschildduruse durchführen.
Ja, eine Ultraschalldiffschildduruse.
Vielleicht bei dieser Prüfung soll ich das alte sagen oder die langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es heißt auf langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung.
Normalerweise sagen wir es heute auf Türkisch, aber auf Deutsch weiß ich nicht.
Langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung.
Gegebenenfalls können Sie eine CT-Schilddur durchführen.
CT-Schilddur durchführen.
Bei der Prüfung sollen wir alle Optionen einfach sagen oder vielleicht...
Ja, natürlich. Besonders bezüglich Ihrer Verdachtdiagnose und Ihrer Asyperansialdiagnose sollen Sie nennen.
Zum Beispiel, Sie haben unkontrolliert Arteriehypertonie als Verdachtdiagnose genannt.
Dann sollen Sie, wenn Sie diese Fragen bekommen, langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung nennen.
Oder Asyperansialdiagnose, Hypotherose. Dann sollen Sie Ultraschalldiffschildduruse nennen.
Aber zum Beispiel nennen Sie TIA. Dann sagen Sie auf jeden Fall CT-Schilddur.
Oder Karotid Dopplersonographie.
Bezüglich Ihrer Differentialdiagnose und Ihrer Verdachtdiagnose können Sie ein paar operative Methoden mitgebend überfahren nennen.
Ja, alles gut. Okay.
Nicht alle. Es kommen hier viele verschiedene Differentialdiagnose infrage.
Aber Sie nennen nicht alle. Natürlich. Zwei Differentialdiagnose sind genug.
Und nun bezüglich dieser Diagnose sollen Sie ein paar bilgebende überfahren oder operative Methoden nennen.
Sie haben recht. Aber als realistisch, wenn ich dachte, zum Beispiel für diesen Fall,
kann ich sagen, dass es eine Überdiagnose gibt.
Aber bei der Prüfung sollen wir alle Optionen einfach überfahren.
Ich wollte noch etwas sagen, Ekrem. Vielleicht habe ich es nicht ganz verstanden.
Wenn Sie einen TIA als Differentialdiagnose nennen, dann müssten Sie das auch nennen. Aber Sie haben es nicht gesagt.
Es ist nicht nötig, das zu sagen. Aber wenn Sie das sagen, dann müssten Sie das auch nennen.
Ich frage mich, was Sie in der Prüfung sagen. Ich frage Sie, ob Sie einen Arterialhypatin mit Burnout für einen solchen Patienten haben.
In der Prüfung müssen Sie die operativen Methoden nennen, die man für die Differentialdiagnose nennen.
Wenn Sie einen Hypatin mit Burnout nennen, müssen Sie die Lankseitige Blutturuk-Messung nennen.
Wenn Sie einen Chipoteroze nennen, dann müssen Sie den Chitturuse Ultra-Scherli nennen.
Aber wenn Sie einen anderen Menschen nennen, dann müssen Sie den TIA als Differentialdiagnose nennen.
Sie können auch das Hirn Blutturk, Hirntumor nennen. Dann müssen Sie auch das CT-Shadow, die Karatustop-Larsonographie nennen.
Dann müssen Sie alles nennen.
Aber Sie sagen, dass Sie das alles nennen.
Das ist die Frage.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass Sie das nennen.
Du sagst, dass Sie das CT-Shadow nicht nennen.
Denn dieser Patient hat schon seit 3 Jahren Anisivindel und hat sehr viel Stress.
Ich denke, dass das zu diesem Thema geht.
Es gibt keine großen Veränderungen. Er hat gesagt, dass er in den letzten Jahren mehr hat, aber der Stress ist auch gestiegen.
Du kannst auch das CT-Shadow nennen, aber es ist wichtig, dass man darüber spricht.
Es ist nicht wichtig, ob es richtig oder falsch ist.
Der Test ist nicht realistisch.
Der Test ist nur ein Teil des Testes.
Okay.
Wir würden die Patienten behandeln.
Als erstes würde ich gerne einen Kardiologischen Konsul durchführen.
Wenn es braucht, werden wir Antihepatensivdosen wieder einstellen.
Amlodipin und Beloxok.
Was brauchen wir?
Zum Beispiel ein anderes Medikament.
Und dann ein psychologisches Konsul für den Burnout-Syndrom.
Gewissverlust und eine psychologische Unterstützung empfehle ich.
Und dann eine Lebensstilveränderung, regelmäßig Sport treiben und eine Diät-Einstellung.
Gesunde Ernährung empfehle ich.
Und so. Das was meine empfehlen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ipek, bist du hier?
Danke, Herr Professor.
Okay.
Herr Professor, ich habe heute keine Zeit.
Ich bin nicht bereit.
Ich hoffe, dass du noch mal Zeit hast.
Ich danke dir, wenn du mein Freund bist.
Okay.
Wir werden alle in die Runde sein.
Das ist ein Fall, den ich nicht in meinem Düsseldorf mag.
Weil man nicht weiß, was man tun soll, ob man die Symptome richtig oder falsch sagt, ob man es richtig oder falsch sagt.
Ich sage es zuerst.
In den letzten Jahren ist das Fall nicht unkontrolliert, arteriöle, hypertonisch.
Es ist immer ein Burnout-Syndrom.
Das muss man fragen.
Diese Symptome können auch mit Hypertonie ausgehen.
Deswegen ist diese Frage hier sehr wichtig.
Das wird die Diagnose von Ferdas bezeichnen.
Wenn es so ist, dann ist es ein Burnout-Syndrom.
Wenn es so nicht ist, dann ist es unkontrolliert, arteriöle, hypertonisch.
Das war auch ein ganz guter Fall.
Er hat es vor ein paar Wochen gemessen, aber er hat nicht gefragt, wie hoch die Symptome ist.
Wenn er das nicht weiß, muss er es beantworten.
Das ist die grundlegende Sache bei diesem Fall.
Ich habe diese Frage gefragt, wie ich das machen muss.
Diese Frage kommt mit Schwindel.
Sie können sich die Fragen über Schwindel beantworten.
Manchmal kann man es sich selbst sagen, aber wenn man es sich selbst sagt, kann man es nicht.
Aber wenn man es nicht sagt, kann man es sich selbst sagen, wie lange es hier ist, wie lange es hier geht, ob es in der Form der Atak ist, ob es immer noch ist.
Wenn man es sehr lange hat, dann sagt man, dass man es bei einem Hausarzt hat.
Wenn man es sehr lange hat, also wenn man es zwei Wochen lang hat, dann fragt man die Hausarzt-Fraktion.
Das bedeutet, dass man wissen kann, was da passiert ist.
Wenn man Schwindel hat, dann fragt man die Hausarzt-Fraktion.
Ich habe mir vorher schon ein paar Fragen über Neurologie gestellt, weil ich meine Anamnesis so oft halte.
So kann man es sagen, wenn ein Hausarzt eine Neurologie besucht, dann fragt man die Hausarzt-Fraktion.
Oder haben sie sich verhört?
Haben sie sich verhört?
Oder haben sie schon einmal ein Beweis verloren?
So ein paar neurologische Fragen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Lehmung, Kribbel, Type-8 haben?
So habe ich es generell gemacht.
Das ist ein Abfall von der Lehmung.
Aber die Leidenschaften entgegenleiten die Leidenschaften.
Aber da gibt es auch einige Fragen.
Um das Symptom nicht auf die Erinnerung zu sieben.
Wie viel Leidenschaften haben Sie?
Wo eben haben Sie diese Leidenschaften?
Wir haben uns dafür ein paar Fragen gestellt.
Aber die Leidenschaften sind eine Faktor.
Die Leidenschaften sind eine Faktor.
Wenn Sie sich die Schmerzen für eine lange Zeit fragen,
können Sie die Schmerzen nicht erinnern.
Sie sind sehr lange Zeit lang da,
weil Sie die Schmerzen nicht erinnern.
Deswegen kann man ein paar Fragen darüber stellen.
Dann kann man über die Koks,
über Übillkait und Erbrahain,
die sich schon oft zusammenführen.
Deswegen kann man über Übillkait und Erbrahain
hier fragen.
Dann kann man direkt an die vegetative Anamnese gehen.
Dann kann man auch nicht nur über die Schmerzen fragen,
sondern auch über die Obst,
aber auch über die Nichteure.
Deshalb kann man die Schmerzen einander fragen.
Wir sagen, dass der Schmerz ein Problem ist.
Dann kann man die Schmerzen erinnern.
Das ist auch so.
Ich frage die Schmerzen nicht,
dann kann ich sie nie erinnern.
Deswegen kann man ein Problem haben,
wie z.B.
Haben Sie Bruce Shmertzsson, Lufnod, Engelgefurlo, da Herschrazen bemerkt
Oder Leiden Sie Unta Bruce Shmertzsson
Hers...
Hani, Hib Hauben dememek için
Ben de bunnere mesel şöyle çeviriyodum
İşte, Hauben Sieyle söylyyodsem
Başke bi soroda haben Sie bemerk diyodum
Başke bi soroda Leiden Sie Unta Bula Bula diyodum
Başke bi soroda İstinin Avgefaldın dassi Bula Bula Hauben diyodum
Hani, sürekli Hauben Hauben dememekcün
Ich habe diese Beleuchtung von den Leuten, die ich mitgebracht habe.
Dann habe ich auch die Fragen von Bruce Shimer, Lufnod, Herzrasen, Engelgefühl.
Dann habe ich Apathit, Gewicht und Schlagprobleme.
Ich habe vier Gruppen geplant.
Fiba, Shutulfros, Nachschweiß, Kassowasch, Schwazausbrüche,
Inapetens, Apathit, Gewicht, Schlagprobleme.
Dann habe ich Lungen, Herz, Bruce Shimer, Engelgefühl, Lufnod, Herzrasen,
Apathit, Gewicht, Apathit, Schlagprobleme, Wassalasenprobleme.
So vieles geht nicht von mir aus.
Wir haben hier keine Fragen über Herz-Ausgabe,
aber das kann auch sein.
Wenn die Pflüfer mich über diese Fragen fragen,
dann kann ich diese Fragen über Herz-Ausgabe,
aber das kann auch als Herz-Ausgabe,
die Dieserfragen und Hurdend-Fernand genannt werden.
Ich wollte auf diesen Fragen stehen,
denn das war ein schwieriger Fall für mich.
Das war mein Genes, die Frage zu stellen.
Ich bin sehr verabschiedet, ich muss die Tür öffnen.
Ich habe für Vera versucht,
die Fragen zu stellen, die ihr vorhin schon gesagt habt.
Wegetatifamnesis oder Kofschimersen,
Zeischtung, Hörstung usw.
Aber es ist nicht in den Test gelungen.
Ja, wenn man sich unter Stress befindet,
ist es natürlich nicht gelungen.
Wenn man es so macht, wird man sich an die Frage stellen.
Wenn man sich an meine Formel schaut,
kann man die Fragen nicht stellen.
Ich habe sie alle in der Anamnesie nicht gefragt.
Ich habe die wichtigsten Fragen für diese Situation gewählt.
Es ist nicht möglich, alles zu stellen.
Aber was man sich an die Fragen stellt,
ist nicht wichtig.
Wenn man die Fragen stellt,
wird man sich schon etwas an die Hände nehmen.
Das ist ein bisschen ein Begriff.
Ich muss die Nörologen-Fragen stellen.
Ich frage die Nörologen-Fragen.
Dann geht es weiter.
Wenn ich ein Symptom bekomme,
werde ich ihn etwas in die Anamnesie innen.
Dann geht es weiter.
Ich werde die Anamnesie innen.
Ich werde die Nektar- und V-Auf-Fragen innen.
Jetzt die Reaktionen.
Was war die erste Reaktion?
Warum fragt man die Personaldatum?
Ich habe immer gesagt,
das sagen einige Patienten.
Ekrem hat hier auch eine sehr schöne Reaktion.
Diese Fragen sind für uns wichtig,
um sie nicht mit anderen Patienten
mit gleichem Namen und gleichem Alter zu verwechseln.
Ich habe immer gesagt,
das sagen alle Patienten.
Was waren die anderen Reaktionen?
Die Frurente Reaktion
möchte man normalerweise mit Oberars
mitnehmen.
Ekrem hat nicht in diese Richtung gegangen.
Deshalb musste ich diese Fragen nicht fragen.
Ich möchte aber nicht, dass ich das nicht möchte.
Die Frurente Reaktion
möchte ich nicht.
Aber ich möchte nicht, dass ich das nicht möchte.
Die Frurente Reaktion
möchte ich nicht.
Ich möchte nicht.
Aber hier ist es wichtig,
dass nicht nur die Patienten
die Frurente Reaktion nicht verhindern.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir diese Systeme
den Prüferen zeigen.
Hier sieht man,
dass die Frurente Reaktion
nicht verhindern.
Aber wenn ein Patient sagt,
dass seine Bruder-Doktorin helfen kann,
dann kann er das nicht.
Wenn ich die Diagnose
und die Befunde
beobachte,
dann kann ich das nicht.
Aber ich habe von uns
eine Entlassungbrief.
Daran kann ich mich selbst
beantragen.
So habe ich es versucht.
Ich habe versucht,
die Frurente Reaktion
zu zeigen,
dass ich die Reaktion
von den Patienten beantragen kann.
Wenn die Patienten
nicht mehr zuhören,
dann kann ich sie beantragen.
Ich kann sie beantragen,
wenn sie nicht mehr zuhören.
Wie kann ich es?
Sie können die Diagnose
und die Befunde
beantragen.
Ich wollte das so machen.
So hätte ich mich darum gehalten.
Sehen wir uns doch mal an.
Die PTPT kann man schreiben, aber in der Danish-Gruppe hat auch Ikra gesagt, dass wir das nicht schreiben können.
Das kann nur der Hausarzt oder der Arztdoktor, der ihn immer folgt, schreiben.
Deswegen, ich habe in dieser Situation auch gesagt,
natürlich, wenn ich das nicht mache, dann ist das nicht meine Blutdruck.
Aber wenn ich die Blutdruck nicht mache, dann kann ich das mit meinem Hausarzt schreiben.
Das ist auch der Fall.
Und wenn ich das nicht mache, dann kann ich das nicht schreiben.
Das ist die Zuka-Schtafigkeit.
Ich habe hier gesagt, dass ich die Blutdruck nicht mache,
natürlich, wenn ich das nicht mache, dann kann ich das mit meinem Hausarzt schreiben.
Das kann auch sein.
Aber das kann mit dem Geld sein.
Wenn man das schreibt, dann wird es etwas festgestellt.
Deswegen, das kann man schon machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das kann man fragen.
Das kann man sagen.
Nur die Hysterik ist nicht genug.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Dann kann man auch sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das kann man auch sagen.
Sie haben sich auch von hinten entfernt.
Das müssen wir alle wissen, auch für den Prätisienhekmonat.
Aber wir können uns noch mehr Details sagen, aber ich denke, dass sie uns warten werden.
Genau, die Ersatzung mit Ersatzung ist nicht in Ordnung.
Auch nicht in Ordnung für die Analyse der Patient.
Jetzt, ich bin hier noch...
Jetzt, was es um den Patienten geht, das ist sehr wichtig.
Also Reaktionen auf den Patienten.
Die Patientin, die immer sagt, sich auf die Beine zu beachten und ihr Reaktion zu geben.
Zum Beispiel, sie sagt, sie hat sehr viel Stress und sie sieht das nicht.
Es ist nicht richtig, etwas anderes zu machen.
Zum Beispiel, was hat Ekrem abend gemacht?
Oder, er hat die Patientin gesagt, sie hat auch Stress auf ihre Privatleben.
Darf ich fragen, warum sie in Privatleben stressig sind?
Zum Beispiel, um etwas zu erzählen.
Vielleicht wird sie von ihrem Mann zu sagen, ich bin zufrieden.
Oder sie ist in einer Situation, die sie zufrieden ist.
Was passiert ist, dass ich sie zufrieden bin, sie zufrieden bin, sie zufrieden bin.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Das zeigt, dass ich die Patienten mit der Analyse verfolgen kann.
Ich muss nichts über die Analyse sagen.
Ich habe das gehört, dass ich sie zufrieden bin.
Sie hat mir ein paar Dinge erzählt.
Dann habe ich sie gesagt, ich muss sie so und so machen.
Das ist eine sehr schwierige Situation für mich.
Das ist fertig.
Du kannst das mit der Stress-Ausgabe erzählen.
Oder du kannst das mit den schwierigen Situationen erzählen.
Nur um zu zeigen, dass du sich mit der Analyse interessiert hast.
Die Patientin hat ein paar Mal die Situation mit der Stress-Ausgabe erzählt.
Sind diese Karten in Ihren Noten, Ms. Suhirah?
Was?
Die Stress-Ausgabe.
Nein, das ist in der Pfalz-Sitzung.
Die Patientin hat die Stress-Ausgabe erzählt.
In diesen Situationen kannst du das mit der Analyse erzählen.
Hast du diese Antworten?
Ich kann sie nicht erinnern.
Dann bitte ich, eine Sitzung zu dieser Stress-Ausgabe zu erzählen.
Aber ich habe die Analyse schon aufgesucht.
Du kannst das später aufhören.
Ich habe die Analyse schon aufgesucht.
Ich habe direkt gehofft, dass ich die Analyse nicht weiß, wie ich das verhandeln kann.
Ich habe die Analyse schon aufgehört.
Vielleicht kann ich die Analyse noch besser erzählen.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen, was du tun solltest.
Ich habe dich gehört und ich frage mich, was du tun solltest.
Dann sagt er, dass es genug ist.
Sie können regelmäßig Sport und eine Manie mit ihren Freunden oder Freundinnen treffen.
Sie können ihnen helfen.
Natürlich kann ich ihnen gerne einen Spezialisten, einen Psychologen empfangen.
So etwas kann auch erzählt werden.
Wenn ich sie noch nicht weiß.
Dann, bei den Todesmöglichkeiten der Mutter und der Vater,
das ist sehr wichtig, das tut mir leid, für ihre Ferlus.
Das kann man sagen.
Sie haben es vor 10 oder 20 Jahren verloren.
Das passt zu allen.
Dann kann man sagen, dass sie es in den letzten Jahren verloren haben.
Ich habe es für die beiden nicht verursacht, das tut mir leid für ihre Ferlus.
Ist es so?
Haben Sie etwas über Reaktionen zu fragen?
Ich habe diese Noten bekommen.
Von den Reaktionen, die mit dem Patient handeln.
Dann, jetzt.
Ekrem, wenn Sie den Patienten die Diagnose sagen,
sagen Sie Uncontrollierte Hypertone, dann Zogenante Burnout Syndrome.
Die beiden sind anders.
Die beiden sagen nicht, dass sie den Patienten die Diagnose machen.
Uncontrollierte Hypertone ist genug.
Die beiden sind anders.
Zogenante ist nicht für Burnout Syndrome.
Ich würde den Patienten für Burnout Syndrome sagen,
ich habe den Patient auf eine körperliche und silische Erschöpfung.
Aber das bleibt nicht eine Vermutung.
Deswegen müssen wir weiter unter der Suche führen.
Und das ist bestätigend.
Uncontrollierte Hypertone, das würde ich sagen,
ich habe den Patient auf eine Uncontrollierte Bluthochdruck.
Aber das bleibt nicht eine Vermutung.
Deshalb würde ich weiter unter der Suche führen.
Der Patient kann nicht verstehen, dass wir Burnout Syndrome sind.
Deswegen ist er auf eine körperliche und silische Erschöpfung.
Und er ist besser.
Burnout ist wirklich nicht gut.
Das kommt mir nicht an.
Nein, das ist wirklich normal.
Ich habe mir das am Ende des Übungs gesagt.
Deswegen teile ich es jetzt mit Ihnen.
Ja, was ist das, was Sie mit diesem Fall fragen möchten?
In den letzten vier Minuten kommt ein anderer Grupp.
Ich hoffe, dass es für Sie ein kleinererer Fall war.
Kann ich etwas zugeben?
Halter hat gesagt,
Halter wird in der Türkei falsch genannt.
Ambulatör und EKG für 24-h-Mitglieder sind generell Halter.
Aber Halter ist ein spezielles Bezeichnis für 24-h-EKG-Trennung.
Das ist es.
Wir können es für Tensionenmöglichkeiten,
Langfristig oder Fearless-Vanseh,
24-h-Mitglieder,
Ambulantess-Mitglieder
oder Langsight, drei bezeichnen.
Aber wenn man Halter sagt,
wird der EKG falsch genannt.
Vielen Dank.
Es war eine sehr faszinierende Lesung.
Danke.
Bis morgen.